depuis quatre ans cette parcelle est à
l'abandon quatre ans de friches ce
terrain ici film où les stats et 29
minutes carey qui a été acheté par la
commune il ya quatre ans ont en projet
d'un lotissement un lotissement en
suspens les premières fouilles
archéologiques ont révélé des vestiges à
moins d'un mètre de profondeur
poterie pièce traces de voirie la
plupart daté du deuxième et du troisième
siècle des fouilles complémentaires sont
à réaliser avant tous travaux la commune
n'en a pas les moyens
pour l'instant j'ai pas de devis précis
là-dessus mais on va quand même donné un
prix qui varie entre 10 et 20 euros du
mètre sur 9000 m² je vous laisse faire
la multiplication en sachant qu'après il
nous est impossible de pouvoir intact et
là ce prix de revient sur le dossier sur
la vente des terrains on est
complètement dehors du marché sur la
commune ce n'est pas le premier
programme immobilier à l'arrêt sur ce
terrain en centre bourg
il devait y avoir un lotissement de 26
maisons le maître d'oeuvre a jeté
l'épongé et le problème touche aussi les
particuliers
cet agriculteur a hérité d'une parcelle
riche en vestiges
les premières fouilles
bon c'est encore finançables ça va mais
s'il ya des fausses il ya des qui
trouvent des anciennes fouilles et bien
c'est un cookie qui est pas raisonnable
pour un propriétaire constructibles son
terrain restera un champ d'avoine toutes
ces restrictions sur une commune comme
bonne et ça veut dire que pas de
développement pas de nouveaux habitants
pas d'enfant fermeture des classes on
est obligé de mutualiser l'école avec la
commune des bords d'à côté un surcoût
bien évidemment
l'élu espère une réforme sur le
financement des fouilles archéologiques
qui devrait avoir lieu en septembre